let me start then and
it's a pleasure for me to see you all
here and it's very nice to be here as
well and in my presentation i would
like to talk about how i am using python
and its features
to make sure that we um allow for the
efficient pcr design and solve one of um
hardest problems which we
encounter during that
solution during that problem solution
so here is
here is an agenda first i would like to
get some introduction some overview of
what of what we are going to do here
then i will uh talk about the general
approach to the problem we are going to
solve
and uh provide uh some hints of how we
did a final solution right
then i will talk about the results and
provide summary and then i will try to
answer your questions
so let me start from far far away a bit
far away right
um i think is that a polymer
polymerase chain reaction um
is useful in many aspects uh we can see
here some examples of uh
when it's used for example if you want
to see uh what
mutations siblings dna or for example
you would like to produce some vectors
using um
predefined uh template or we want to see
uh what are presenting
bacterias in differ in different media
or for example you would like to
assess the sequence of different
mutations
or if
if you would like to pick up compounds
which are
tropic to some specific targets in
drug design that's dna encoded libraries
we could use a pcr as a means to achieve
our tasks
so
how it's used actually
we have a template it's a dna sequence
and that template needs to be amplified
for our purposes right and the driving
force of that amplification is a set of
primers uh and probes um
we basically need two primers and the
probe for example if we want to execute
a real-time polymerase chain reaction
and uh that
ligand nucleotides need to be designed
in advance
uh primers are on course for their
premier race
and
probes allowed to identify the
quantities of
amplifying
of the template being amplified
so what is the flow we need to first
generatorize
our sequence our dna sequence then
primers and probes get quenched they
attach to the
denaturized dna sequence
then
polymerase attaches to
the primer to the sides where primers
are allocated
and
the
process of
extension begins
as soon as it completes
we cool down the solution and
repeat the steps again so we have
amplifying we have getting
amplifying sequences
and uh each step produces twice as much
dna sequence as before
so that's uh
the idea and
the question is how to properly identify
primers and probes how to properly
design them to get the best results
possible for our purpose
so that pcr design has some
peculiarities um
i think that template uh might continue
constitute
up to of up to 5 000
base pairs and that produces a lot of um
different uh combinations which we need
to evaluate to pick up the best design
so
that number of combinations might uh
become up to 1 million and it's huge
number and thing is that we need to
produce the design quite fast
and efficiently
so there are several keys key parameters
to consider in that design and um
the thing is that one of them is
that we need to minimize the presence of
self foldings and dimers formed by
primers and probes
and uh that's a um a difficult task to
identify such structures and uh
it's it's quite time consuming and that
hampers the design speed
so we need to find uh the best way to
identify such structures
and the thing is that this problem of
identifying such structures
is a constraint and highly non-convex
optimization problem actually
so in order to find the best ones we
need to come up with um
some algorithm with which allows to
identify basically uh the global minima
in this problem right
so
when basically on the right side we can
see uh here
is it working
an example of second of a secondary
structure this is a
self-folding of a dna sequence right
so uh what is the essence of the problem
uh we need to detect uh those structures
at a high speed because
the number of combinations we need to
consider is quite huge
and we need to analyze every single
elegant nucleotide in the
design against secondary structures and
dimers
and also we need to
identify
cross dimers and self dimers right
so
i think is that those problems of
identification of self foldings and
dimers is quite similar
but still it's
necessary to come up with some efficient
algorithm which allows to identify those
things
so
basically there is um a classical
secure algorithm which id allows to
identify uh secondary structures but the
thing is that it doesn't allow to
identify dimers at the moment
so um
and that
algorithm is um
has the complexity of an in the third
degree uh in time
and uh
that algorithm um
turns out to be attending uh two
multi-branched and less stable
structures
so we
it it means that if um it fails um false
into
that local minimum
its predictions are not accurate enough
and uh the final pcr design might fail
actually
so um
yeah thing is that we need needed to
solve for those problems and here is
basically a outcome of some outcome
so this is uh the structure predicted by
sukher algorithm this is a structure
observed in in the natural setting this
is a structure
which we managed to predict ourselves so
it's i would say it's much closer both
in terms of energy and melting
temperature
so the approaches are pretty simple uh
we decided that uh it's necessary to
solve the steiner tree problem
but before we do that we need uh to
select the nodes of the tree we are
going to build
or trees we are going to build
so we start from uh building an
energetic table
uh then vp cup chains its uh set of
sequences um
i would say a double stranded sequences
right
and then we need to pick up such
combinations of chains uh which produce
uh
basically the steiner tree and here we
can see um the numbers associated with
each of the steps
which result in the steiner tree
so
we can see that
all the steps
have the complexity of n squared
and it's uh i would say more efficient
than
uh initial uh algorithm provided by
itsuki
so uh basically in order to build the
tree we needed to pick up uh several
metrics which allowed to uh find out the
best
notes of the tree right
so we start from
the high energetic uh
chains
so we needed to come up with
metrics associated with
with energy of the chains
then uh we needed to evaluate uh
energy densities of combinations of the
trees of the chains
and uh cut off
the chain combinations which have a high
energy
high energy density
and when that is done we need to filter
out the trees with high energy because
those trees are associated with
secondary structures so dimers with
high energy and low melting temperatures
so
um how we build the energetic table uh
we need to pick up the sequence
and its reverse and then
combine uh each
consequent uh
letters uh into uh pairs
this is the so-called um
nearest neighbor approach uh and we can
see there are numbers
yeah and those numbers associated with
energies of the stacks so for example if
we look at this one
it's uh
it's forming uh
right it's forming
as a
combination which is uh
partially
how to
say partially
complementary which is partially
complementary and the next one is
completely complementary and this
produces some energy which is
below zero right the next combination is
complementary as well and it produces
energy below zero and so on so we pick
up sequences of uh
those
combinations and uh those combinations
are called chain section
so um this is how we build the energetic
table and uh
think is that for secondary structures
we need to uh not to cross this yellow
line because it uh basically it's a
constraint associated with mass
conservation law
so
when yeah
it means that it doesn't
form uh some
complementary uh sequence
so for example um if we have a look at
some i don't know zero z uh
but i see there like the first line when
you go g
yeah
that means exactly that the thing is
that we need to consider two consequent
uh letters and two consequent lenders
associated with some energy
uh which is coming from uh the
predefined tables uh of the nearest
neighbor method
so uh in in accordance in accordance to
that um
to those tables and the method we just
summate the energies of the consequent
letters for example if you have a look
at this one
and uh i do not know
we
take this one and this one
this one and this one and come up with
energy of this particular
helix right ta
ja
is a ta
ta
yeah and as far as i can see it's
no it's
it's ct
city and
gg
so it produces some uh energy which is
below uh zero right
but uh the next letter which is coming
into the sequence uh produces
non-complementary uh structure and the
energy is zero therefore
so it's uh as soon as this energetic
table is built based on the nearest
neighbor tables
we analyze that energetic table and see
what are the chains presented in that
table so we can
see for example here this one or this
one this those are the chains right the
sequences of table of letters which are
complementary or partially complementary
so uh
when we build those chains we also need
to see the free space associated with
those
chains for the secondary structures so
for example this one would be the cutoff
because
otherwise we wouldn't be able to build
the hairpins associated with
the chain
so uh and also i should notice that uh
we do not consider as a combination the
chains which overlap so
those should be filtered out
so
uh i think is that those chains have
energy volume it's the energy multiplied
by uh the lengths of uh the chain and
here we can see the distribution of the
chains in uh in the sequence
i would say it's somehow the resembling
pareto distribution but
for some reason it's uh non-convex
in contrast to the pareto distribution
but still and it turned out that we need
to pick up the chains with energies
energy volumes which are less than uh
seventh i did see uh of this
distribution so for example uh
yeah
something somewhere here we just set cut
off and uh the chains with those
energies are only considered
so you can see the code snippet
associated with how we evaluate uh the
frequencies the cumulative frequencies
the distribution function
uh which you can see here
so it's pretty simple but still uh that
number page package allowed to do that
task practicing pretty easy right
and uh as soon as the distribution
function is
built we just perform a pickup of the
cut-off right and
this is the dead seal which i have
mentioned
and it's used to cut off the chains with
energy volumes which are below
the cutoff
so uh the first task is completed and
after that we need to pick up um ss
energy densities those are some some
sums of energy volumes of uh
set of chains for example if we take
this chain and this chain
and then uh we summate energy the energy
volumes of those chains and divide by
the area of this
square right
to assess the energy density
and that energy density has its own
distribution it looks like this
and it turned out that the best way to
cut off
the combinations of chains
is to pick up somewhere here right out
of this
distribution
so
the combinations which they here are
taken out and
we consider only them
for our purposes
uh also you could have seen uh
the quotes input which used yet again we
calculate um
uh the cumulative frequency uh in here
and uh we take uh
the half of uh
i would say a minimum of this value it's
here right and it's a cut off for energy
densities
so
uh in order to to solve the steiner tree
problem we have selected we have already
selected the chains and the combinations
and we just need to traverse through
them
and that is done using
energy density cut off
i believe it's somewhere here right
and
we find the best
neighbor here
uh and that best neighbor is uh taken as
uh
the chain which uh has
the
lowest
energy density
so it's working like this
and as soon as we have combinations of
those chains the steiner tree is
basically built and we have collection
of chains which form the secondary
structural dimer which we need to find
out
so um
i think that those combinations also
have their own metrics and it's possible
to cut off
the trees
which have high energy
sums of energies right
and the less energy is the better
and oh
yeah
so uh
where is the code snippet
and
we have found
uh we have found a total energy cut off
here it is i believe
and everything uh which comes above is
filtered out
that's not the best platonic way of
course i have
already updated this but uh here is uh
outdated code snippet
so um as soon as it's cut off we have
combinations of uh trees which are
energetic enough to produce stable
structures so basically
the problem solved the tasks the task is
resolved and we have found out the
combinations and that's pretty much
technical stuff to convert those
combinations into
structures so here for example we can
see how it's done
uh here is the classical representation
of secondary structures using uh
brackets and dots
and it's pretty simple uh to convert the
combinations of chains uh from the tree
into this uh into those structures right
so i would like to bring up uh the
performance uh i did some benchmarking
it's pretty rough because it's not an
easy
to identify the best i would say um
sequences uh to be analyzed but still
you can see that the trend is uh
somewhere
of uh and squared uh
in the time complexity and
i would like to also mention that
this algorithm is pretty much
easier adjustable to finding out
the dimers itself
as well right we just strip that
constraint of yellow
secondary um
diagonal right which we have seen before
and that's solving our problem out of
the box
so
i think is that a current algorithm
turns out to be finding uh the most
stable structures
in comparison to tsukir it
doesn't stick to multi-branching
structures it
finds
i would say simple foldings which turn
out to be more stable and
that's
one of the key features of that
algorithm
and here is a summary uh so we have uh
found out some metrics associated with
how to efficiently build
those steiner trees and find
the secondary structures and dimers
uh we
apply instant filtering uh to find those
structures
because we need to
reduce the time
required to find those trees and
as soon as those trees are found
basically
we have
our issues solved and
we have a quite performant and robust
predictions algorithm
so that's pretty much it i believe i i'm
ready to answer your questions
no energy is uh um
if you look at the stable
uh energy is the uh energy of uh
the chain right here is the change
which is the age right yeah we need to
talk about ground genes
is energy density
so the less energy density is the better
the more negative energy is the better
it it means that we form uh stable
structures
i just wondering did you consider
the genetic algorithm approach because
i've seen
some minimization and optimization
problems which
genetic algorithm source like
i guess a bit
more
lower
big notations
okay so
is there any approach you consider
no i didn't consider that approach yet
but thank you for the idea
possibly that would be a better approach
i think is that a classical algorithm is
recursive so we just split that sequence
into some subsequences and go and go and
go
trace back and find some some structure
which could be um in place for that dna
right
but still it um if we have a look at the
outcomes uh here is a comparison
um
think is that
the greater this part of the structure
has less energy so it's less stable in
comparison to those two
thank you
[Applause]